hello Amy I have to take a call on my
banana phone hey lad Bible I'm Will
Ferrell and I'm here with Amy Poehler
hey we're going to paint each other's
sweet tender amazing bodies so we're
doing nudes you got to pay a lot of
money to do minutes
do you enjoy art not really can I see
your eyes real quick I thought there's a
reason why they make prisoners do this
[Music]
well I think of you as a piece of art do
you that I think of you as a piece of
art I think of you as like a Rodin
sculpture I just went to the Louvre so
enough of the Louvre I was going to
donate one of my organs for money and I
couldn't go through with it because they
wouldn't write because it was diseased
but give me some nice broad shoulders oh
god I love a broad shoulder on the woman
you're stupid talk about the Louvre I'm
drawing a French beret on your head now
okay that's what you get I have I have a
slight case of operational defiance
disorder do you know what that as well I
don't it means that I don't like to do
the things that people ask me to do
so this painting is operational defiance
disorder what's your favorite bird did
you say seagulls that's what I thought
I'm pretty much done okay this is you on
your trip to France
Wow right the eyes are uncanny if he did
a still-life leave the fruit see that's
good there's some technique there I've
been a bowler
he's Will Ferrell you've watched us
paint each other this is how I see will
is just a bowl of jangly fruit thank you